rien n'est prévu rien n'est organisé
rien n'est pensé sinon une chose
diaboliser notre proposition économique
et social ma personne cela va de soi
mais disons que je suis entraîné samedi
serait même plus ni moins le premier est
là en reste toute la stratégie du
pouvoir dans ces conditions nous avons
été très heureux de voir que au moins un
institut nous critiquer c'est l'institut
montaigne et comme il avait fait le
travail un autre institut qui lui n'a
fait aucun travail qui est la fondation
terra nova a recopié s en est pris à
nous et tant mieux on était content
parce que ça lancer un débat alors
évidemment avant de commencer le débat
nous avons été obligés de procéder à des
rectifications de chiffres car
l'institut montaigne qui est extrêmement
bienveillant c'était juste trompé 30
milliards ceux qui quand même pour des
gens qui prétendent donner des leçons de
rigueur budgétaire manque un petit peu
de discipline mais dès que nous avons
signalé aux auteurs de ce rapport qu'il
s'était trompé ils ont immédiatement
admis et rectifier leur chiffrage si
bien que maintenant nous voici rendus à
70 milliards pour la réforme de la
retraite encore un effort et on arrivera
sur le chiffre réel car je rappelle
comme je l' ai déjà dit à l'occasion de
la séance du chiffrage nous n'avons nous
avons chiffré la totalité de notre
programme économique en le faisant
entrer dans la moulinette de la banque
de france n'est pas une convention entre
mes amis c'est dans l'alcool jeudi la
bouline est c'est la matrice économique
de la banque de france et les chiffres
que nous avons produit en gros que je
vais résumer par donc en gros sont ceux
que vous connaissez
250 milliards seront injectés et
lorsqu'ils auront fini leur circuit
c'est à dire lorsqu'ils ont été utilisés
en investissement lorsqu'ils ont été
distribué en salaires lorsqu'ils ont été
utilisés en équipements et biens de à
l'autre bout remontant taxes en
cotisations sociales d'après cette
matrice de la banque de france 2 167
milliards
la progression de la dépense
ne devrait étonner personne parce que je
suis obligé de rappeler à tous ceux qui
l'ont ignoré que ça correspond
exactement à la progression de la
défense qu'avait organisé le président
jacques chirac souffre évidemment ça
s'applique à d'autres choses que ce à
quoi lui l'avait appliquée voilà tout ça
méritait à notre avis d'être dit de
répondre à vos questions nous avons
voulu le faire dans la plus grande
précision possible pour ma part je vais
aller à la préparation du meeting de ce
soir mes amis et camarades sont là ils
ont chacun à vous présenter un aspect de
ce que nous avons entrepris notre
message que au pays et qu'il peut avoir
confiance en nous
[Musique]